et en suisse est une marathonienne qui a
été emporté par une coulée de neige à
l'est dans un état critique ce soir le
danger s'est encore accentuée ces deux
dernières semaines avec de très fortes
chutes de neige
mais tous les skieurs ne le prennent pas
en compte patrick esther un simple
cordon de plastique et quelques
pancartes
mais pour ceux qui effectuent ce geste
banal de soulever la corde
le danger peut devenir immédiatement
réel car en montagne l'avalanche reste
le risque majeur
rien ne peut l'arrêter il est impossible
de stopper cette force destructrice
les stations de sport d'hiver
connaissent bien et prennent en compte
ce risque pour limiter ses effets par
exemple en analysant tous les jours
la qualité de la neige notamment après
de fortes chutes
un travail auquel les pisteurs sont
formés en permanence comme ici à l'alpe
d'huez par ce qui est intéressant de
savoir sept ans qui l'a fait en début de
saison
et puis pendant pendant toute la saison
pour arriver à avoir une idée s'il a eu
du vent s'il a plus qu'assez des grains
qui ont été mouillés par les chutes de
prix qu'on a eu ces derniers jours donc
ça explique pourquoi ils sont si gros si
visible une connaissance du manteau
neigeux nécessaire pour bien comprendre
les phénomènes physiques et calculer le
niveau de risque d'avalanche une échelle
de 1 à 5 5 pour le risque maximum il
était de 3 avant-hier à val d'isère
tous les matins les pisteurs détermine
les zones les plus dangereuses et
déclenche talent explosif des avalanches
pour purger les couloirs menacée mais il
est bien sûr impossible de purger toute
la montagne
les services de sécurité
balise avec des pancartes ou des cordes
toutes ces zones potentiellement
dangereuses et situés à l'extérieur des
pistes qui elles sont sécurisés alors et
surtout lorsque le drapeau à damier où
le drapeau noir et tisser les skieurs
hors-piste s'amuse à leurs risques et
périls
une pratique qui procure un plaisir
intense
un plaisir qui tue chaque année plus
d'une cinquantaine de personnes en
france
en montagne
l'avalanche reste le risque majeur rien
ne peut l'arrêter il est impossible de
stopper cette force destructrice
pourtant les stations de sports d'hiver
connaissent bien et prennent en compte
ce risque
pour limiter ces effets par exemple en
analysant tous les jours la qualité de
la neige notamment avec un prof un
travail auquel un pisteur sont formés
comme ici à l'alpe d'huez par ce qui est
intéressant de savoir c'est tant pis
d'affaires début de saison et puis
pendant toute la saison pour arriver à
avoir une idée s'il a eu du vent s'il a
plus qu'assez des grains qui ont été
menées par les chutes de pluie qu'on a
eu ces derniers jours donc ça explique
pourquoi ils sont si grosses si visible
une connaissance du manteau neigeux
nécessaire pour bien comprendre les
phénomènes physiques et prévoir le
niveau de risque d'avalanche une échelle
de 1 à 5 5 pour un risque maximum il
était à 3 avant-hier à val d'isère
tous les matins les pisteurs détermine
les zones les plus dangereuses et
déclencher un explosif
les avalanches pour purger les couloirs
menacée
mais il est bien sûr impossible alors
j'ai tout l'amour pas alors les services
de sécurité balise avec des pancartes ou
avec des cordes toutes ces zones
potentiellement dangereuses et situés à
l'extérieur des pistes qui elles sont
sécurisés certaines stations interdisent
même le ski hors piste mais il est
fréquent de voir des skieurs ou des
surfers soulevé la corde est passé outre
à leurs risques et périls
surtout si le drapeau à damier le
drapeau noir et tisser une pratique hors
piste qui procure un plaisir intense
mais qui tue chaque année plus d'une
cinquantaine de personnes